you've already heard on this channel of
the death touch
but have you heard of the healing touch
this is a picture of a brain tumor it's
the hardest kind of tumor to heal and
operate on
yet astonishingly a tumor that looks
like this can dissolve
and vanish without surgery chemotherapy
drugs or any risky procedures
whoa getting into it today boys ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host scott
vizilla and today yes yes yes
we're talking about health it's
important to me it's important to you i
know i i know i know it is
you know you got health you don't have
it if you don't
people want to sell you some magic
formula just like the death touch
miraculously saved us if we needed to
defeat our foes
i don't know if you guys watched that
video go watch it right here just like
that now there's
healing touches ladies and gentlemen
we're investigating them today because
uh let's say you have cancer this is
gonna interest you a lot
okay let's bring down the the thing and
try not to hit myself there okay
ah touch point technique five times
stronger than chemotherapy vitamins and
antioxidants ladies and gentlemen what
how incredible
call someone call harvard someone call
yale we gotta get the boys on this
i mean we've got a virus going around
ladies and gentlemen let's find out
what's going on
it's a healing method so powerful so
simple to use
and so inexpensive the medical community
will do anything to hide it from us
adding conspiracy yes yes the doctors
want to hurt you yes
right go ahead go ahead those who have
the knowledge to use it are often
regarded as miracle workers
as you watch this video right to the end
you'll not only discover how to turn
your body into the perfect healing
machine
you'll be able to do it yourself and in
as little as five minutes a day
i love how they always go from like they
can't just have an incredible claim
you're gonna heal any problem they also
have to double down and be like
in five minutes it's like it's not like
hey
we figured out a cure alzheimer's it's
we figured out how to cure alzheimer's
in five minutes no surgery nothing
required it's incredible man
hard to believe yes not after you hear
the true story of charles
what would you who's charles it's not
like charles anderson it's just it's
just
charles of course it is you do if your
child had a tumor that doctors could not
remove
if they tried the risk of death for your
child or someone you love was so high
that it was an almost guaranteed death
sentence but if on the small chance that
the surgery worked
your child or loved one's face would be
horrifically disfigured for life
that's a decision charles had to face
stock footage of old man
google search please his daughter was
supposed to die
yet as you are about to hear he
discovered a third option
it was a long shot but it was one he was
willing to take
and the result well you can judge that
for yourself after you is a different
person by the way everyone
see that that's stupid the birth of his
daughter was easily the happiest moment
in charles's life but the joy didn't
last long because soon a dentist noticed
a small bean-sized growth in his
daughter's upper lip
it took his daughter to see a doctor
surely since he caught it early
modern medicine would provide a way to
remove it since it was still such a
small growth
hasn't she been through enough guys i'm
already now emotionally invested of this
i was going to disprove this but now i'm
emotionally invested in the bean sized
growth here
but his hopes crashed when he was told
by the doctor that it was a blood vessel
tumor
and that it was in a place where surgery
couldn't be performed
charles thought maybe it would stay
harmless that it would stay small and
benign
but the tumor steadily swelled the
doctors predicted she had only six
months to live
a shroud of sadness covered their family
helplessly they watched their child
slowly choke to death a friend suggested
tcm
or traditional chinese medicine as a
last resort
charles was desperate hey she's gonna
live guys the music changed did you hear
that
the stock music and the stock footage
has changed now it's gonna be
okay how do you make up these wild
stories about like
child death in order to sell your your
garbage
product it's amazing to me the the level
of
psychopathy involved in these internet
marketers they just make up these
stories they're like hey what
charles what his daughter died can we
say anything else
oh yeah it actually came back more
aggressive than ever and
she actually watched his daughter's
choke to death that's cool
furiously and desperately researching
the options he found a center in china
renowned for curing the most chronic and
terminal diseases
they did what it took landed in china
and made a beeline straight for the
center
this was his last hope however in a mere
24 days his daughter's tumor not only
stopped growing but also began to shrink
but he had run out of his savings
desperate to stay longer
what a twist here she's about to live
but
he ran out of savings i can't get me to
the point where she lives please
created manual labor for him and his
daughters to stay longer one day
charles's hopes were realized
the tumor was gone completely gone
now this story and the others just like
it that you're about to hear
aren't unusual just because cancer
crippling arthritis viral infections
even as severe as aids
autoimmune diseases like diabetes
migraines
allergies and extreme mental disorders
were all completely cured
oh so it just cures everything i get it
everyone knows
china doesn't have any illness because
of traditional chinese medicine everyone
knows that
right yet they are still kept mainly out
of view to mainstream america
they are safe gentle natural and
powerful western medicine and large
pharmaceutical companies
simply cannot lose their monopoly on the
industry of surgery medication and drugs
i love how some random internet
marketers like hey
those guys they're greedy listen i think
the only person worse
than big pharma are internet marketers
actually i think you guys does
like if if big pharma you know people
like the sackler brothers or whatever
if they're like in the fifth circle of
hell there's a people underneath
for sure internet marketers definitely
and i'm not saying all internet
marketers by the way obviously
but the people who produce this
definitely go into health
i may be forced to by the powers that be
to take this free video down it might be
shut down by the federal trade
commission
because it should be this is psychotic
how suddenly even tumors in cancer cells
can begin to melt away
and how asthma sufferers can suddenly
feel like they are taking their first
deep breath in decades i'm going to
teach you the secret in just a second
but before i do
i need to talk about the big lie that's
keeping you your family or dear friends
from being free from needless illnesses
physical pain and disease now let me
guess
big parma think you'll see why i feel
it's my duty to share it with you
so please stay with me the big lie is
that a cure for the most debilitating
and fatal diseases today
can only be treated with medical drugs
and surgery and that any natural cure
doesn't exist
as i'm about to prove to you in just a
minute how a natural
inexpensive non-chemical cure does in
fact exist
what i love about this like a little
robot voice they have going on here
for somebody who's pretending to be
brave like i'm coming out with a big
secret
who are the people behind this i have
looked for a long time
at who makes this stupid thing of course
they're nowhere to be found
with something called clover seven
nutraceuticals or something who owns
that nobody knows george bridgem who's
he nobody knows it's all a fake name
so that's the thing that really pisses
me off because these people they go oh
i've got the secret
but i'm keeping my face a secret that's
how you know all this stuff is a scam
they don't tell you who they are you
can't hold them accountable
nothing the truth is your body already
has the power to kill any harmful germ
virus bacteria or dysfunction by using
this powerful
safe gentle and unusual five-minute
exercise
there's a reason why some people and
even entire cultures managed to live
their
entire lives without debilitating
illnesses the big secret the ancient
chinese discovered and have been using
for thousands of years to reverse any
illness
including cancer aids clogged arteries
arthritis diabetes alzheimer's
yeast isn't it enough is it cancer
enough carrying cancer
you have to throw in heart disease and
alzheimer's just to give it make it a
little tougher for you be too easy to
just cure cancer
used in china for thousands of years to
heal millions of people its potent
abilities still find its way
into mainstream culture now who's
actually behind this whole thing
the whole scam well we have
this guy i don't know if he knew what he
was getting into but he was hired by
these internet marketers
he's supposedly the the guy behind it
all there's always a guru behind it guys
as you know from fake guru
now we're going to learn about who's
behind the touch point
technique five times stronger than
chemotherapy vitamins and antioxidants
let's go
china in singapore name master lin
he is easily the most humble man i've
ever met in my life
i actually had a hard time believing
this humble soft-spoken man was the
source of
all the stories i kept hearing about
performing such miraculous
feats of healing stories like how a man
was suddenly struck with a deadly heart
attack in a subway
and master lim who happened to be there
was able to use his deep understanding
of meridian points
to literally massage the heart attack
away hey
okay we gotta address that right now
massage the heart attack away first of
all
demonetized okay we can't show that
demonetized
massage the heart attack away though
they've been doing it wrong all the time
they've been zapping people
unnecessarily
all you need is a little massage from
master lim here
just by placing a few fingers on a
specific part of the man's body
he was able to neutralize the heart
attack on the spot without question
this saved the man's life as it took a
long time for the paramedics to
come so what i want to tell you guys
right now let me just spoil it this is
obviously a gigantic
scam but not only is it a gigantic scam
it's a gigantic scam
that's existed for a very long time and
these monsters who keep recycling this
stuff
are faking literally everything inclu
including master lim
so uh i got behind their paywall of
course and i got into the modules
and this guy's basically like just like
teaching you like rub yourself in the
back and is like going to cure your
cancer or whatever
uh it's like basic stretching right
because of course it's not
magical healing formulas for 39.95
online that the doctors don't want you
to know about i mean i'm sorry to tell
you
but these scumbags are using like
traditional chinese medicine
which you know has its place in the
world it's just its place is not curing
cancer
i guess this is like healing your arm i
mean is this could master limb
magically regrow your arm with this
tapping technique uh but what i want to
show you guys is that this has existed
since actually back in like to the early
2000s there was something called
pure natural healing so this is a modern
thing but this is a literally a redo
of this which is pure natural healing
which is harvard confirms you know
pain relief heart health and optimal
blood pressure without drug surgery or
just beginning of this odd therapy
and in this the same guy is used for the
same thing except
the story is different instead of being
a singaporean man
he's a chinese man see this is a scam
review from
contra health scam and they talk about
the fact that he was the chinese wonder
healer
a few years ago and miraculously now
he's become a singaporean
healer not only that last time is george
brigham uh the previous version
was a guy named keith richardson which
was just a uh shutterstock photo
because of course it was so these guys
who are saying like oh
down with pharma right which is you know
the problem is is they
use it because they have a point right
farm has done some shady stuff for sure
but they use that to then sell you even
worse snake oil so they go to people
who are like tired frustrated uh sick
the most desperate and they go hey
aren't you tired of those guys taking
advantage of you
it's so sick it's so sick and we have to
call it out
but yeah all their testimonials are fake
as well they're all
shutter stock images so literally even
these things about like
it saved my life whatever it's all crap
it's all made up
by some scumbag in his mom's basement
trying to make a quick buck
so guys what's the conclusion here is
there such thing as a
healing touch just like there was the
death touch
unfortunately not turns out to be not
only a scam
but a recycled scam from years ago
that some scumbag internet marketer is
using to uh
extract wealth and rent seek from all
desperate
sick people how long are we gonna get
away with this
it's how long are they gonna be allowed
to promise cures to cancer
and not only trick westerners but also
belittle
traditional chinese medicine as well how
long is it gonna happen
let me know in the comments below what
you think and uh in the meantime i wish
you
all the very best sorry guys try to heal
myself here um
because this video has given me cancer
wake up and smell the coffee